but yeah so my voice is gone from
screaming during the uh marvel animation
panel which was great oh my god the
marvel animation was so good there's
there are a few worries that i have and
some things i'm really excited about
um for example i'm a little unsure about
the whole x-men 97 like the actually in
the animated series has always been a
show
that i dealt with look at look at this
um
but yeah expert 97 is always going to
show that where the x-men have kind of
been like the minority and it dealt with
the idea of minorities and you know uh
groups being oppressed different things
like that which i'm fine with um i think
that's an important part of the x-men
mythos and i think that needs to be
addressed i think one of the concerns
that myself and other people have is
that the show might feel like it's just
kind of beating you over the head or
like talking at you or lecturing to you
or something like that and the problem
with doing that is you lose your
audience like people walk away they stop
watching and then your message just
never gets delivered uh plus i don't
want to be taken out of the stout so
there's that spider-man freshman year as
long as i can tell is not going to be in
popularity that's kind of an answer to
the question what would life of peter
parker look like if norman osborne had
been spence for instead of tony stark
and there's a few other characters that
are involved in there that we just
haven't seen yet so i don't know exactly
how that's gonna go uh and then
god what else is there um
i am groot looks amazing it looks
absolutely hilarious it looks like it's
just gonna it's like like i tweeted this
out and it looks like the minions
meets guardians of the galaxy if that
makes any sense right it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be light-hearted it's gonna
be really enjoyable um and it's gonna be
a blast so i'm actually gonna watch it i
think it's gonna be a great show what if
season two they already confirmed season
three they're like season three's
happening but what if season two looks
really really cool in the trailer which
i don't know the trailer's dropped i
think what he had i haven't looked it up
on youtube but um
there was some really cool stuff oh cool
looks like a good way to start letting
people in um
there was some really really cool stuff
so there was like a scene where like
odin thought that we fought win with the
mandarin when he had the 10 rings which
looks really cool marvel 1602 was going
to play a major role in in the what if
like the way it was like the whole
infinity stones and like ultron and all
that kind of stuff in season one marvel
1602 looks like it's gonna be the main
the main event for for what if season
two there is
let's see we gotta see the first episode
no spoilers for that but it's pretty
solid iron man the the episode from
season one where was supposed to be that
iron man lands on the car they're doing
that in season two so that's going to be
cool but yeah i mean the the you know
what if season two looks like it's gonna
be great it really just kind of seems
like it picks up where season one left
off so those are the guys who were
expecting season one for it to be like
the end and season two is just totally
removed it has nothing to do with any of
that stuff that's actually not the case
it just picks back up with like the
rogers um black widow and captain carter
team but she's kind of goes forward and
does their thing so that's going to be
fun um
yeah having said that i mean i'm looking
forward to the marvel zombies you're
going to be ready to tv mature that blew
the mind of everybody in the anastasia
they were just like holy sh mature that
blew everybody's mind which is gonna be
really really cool because it looks like
it's gonna be really really dark so
those of you guys who who are curious
about this imagine if what if was a
marvel max line and that's what it looks
like the show is gonna be which i'm very
excited about because marvel max was
model comics of adult impact right like
violence craziness all kinds of stuff it
was really really good i mean my
question is this is like an offshoot of
the scrolls because
quran what do you think man because the
growl does not though
the
nothing
the scroll the scarons um
the scrolls
were like they were good guys right
like they were nominated
it was implied that they were
mostly like
good guys but also
we only got to see like a really small
sample size of everything that was going
on
and like i do legitimately think it's
the scrolls
because of the fact that there's that
scene where i think it's just nick
theory is like sitting down and he's
surrounded by all of the dudes that look
the same it's not the theory but it is
definitely the squishy yeah
i couldn't remember who was like sitting
down and was just surrounded by dudes
with the same face yeah that's a white
guy i don't recognize but the scrolls i
mean secret invasion is a scroll yeah
exactly
i mean i wonder if it's like a religious
group
i mean the skrulls are religious that's
really like a religious fanatic
because the gore of the god butcher
opens the door for god from other worlds
so what you have are you guys familiar
with the squirrels
yeah
well you are because you're working on
the history of all of you that's true
yeah okay so ron
i'm
you know like the uh in the comics
the celestials came to earth
and they created the deviants the
internals and then
genes would manifest later on in regular
humans so you get be consistent like
that
on earth in the comics
the deviants were basically defeated by
the celestials during the second house
they were all but obliterated they took
off underground and that was the end of
them the eternals remained on earth
there was a bit of a civil war some took
off to saturn that's not even thanos and
then humans inherited them
on scrolls it was not that case it was
not that way
um
the deviant scrolls massacred all the
eternal scrolls for the most part well
they mastered all the baseline scrolls
and there was a war between the deviants
and the eternal scripts yes charlotte
and p3
not shawn keith um
clinton and sluger
these weird ass names
yeah not even lying right jonathan and
kate yeah jonathan
johnson
charlotte
the way it played out in the comics you
had clinton and slicker and i can't
remember which one i want to say
the girl was the deviant
the guy was the intro i believe that was
the case yes
and then basically they went forward it
was what was it affect the deviant
scrolls becoming like the dominant group
of scrolls
um but that's an instance where the
deviants basically won now there were
the dire race but that's a whole
different a whole different piece
um
that's like way outside yeah that's a
whole different that's a whole different
system
yeah so
my idea is what if this is like a
religious they're like religious
sentence
and they're and it's they follow char
and he through some of them they follow
scroll gods
those weird ass names
and like they're they're driven to do
this based on their on their like belief
systems uh
okay i'm trying to remember we all know
if it matters
but secret invasion um that's phase six
no
that's that's the one okay i was i was a
little uh
shape me on that because you're super
tired all we know about phase six is
that we get um
fantastic four and eventually and then
it ends with the two avengers movies we
get two videos movies in one year that's
nuts
just like
is it actually going to work out that
way because they said the same [ __ ] with
uh infinity war and windows in-game they
cut that up then they they cut it up
yeah yeah exactly i think they were
supposed to be how could you see if it
was in one movie
because
because
what i think they're doing here
is i think with the king dynasty and
with cedarwood so much i love your
theory
i think i think the mcu is going a
crisis on the creditors it's multiverse
i think i think they're going to crisis
i think that they are going to
that's another thing they're going to do
for wb
that's bwp at their own i mean yeah they
did their crisis on infinite nurse but
strangely enough it only invented the
arrowverse and ezra miller kind of
showed up before he grew some kid and
took off with it
so yeah
he left the speed force with some
teenager in his you know clutches and
he's doing whatever the hell becoming
the new michael jackson
dude playing the role of corey feldman
is going to be that teenage kid
they ran
they ran away they stopped in hawaii
they pumped somebody and then they were
out yeah
yeah that guy's crazy but no i think
that
that yeah yeah yeah
although there's never been any scene
with the flash that will ever be as good
as bart allen
remember it's smallville
don't talk about this anymore he's like
running a green screen and he turns
around
[Music]
i'm just saying i'm just saying when
like bart allen outrages superman yeah
that's the snake yeah it was great man
at the time it was great why did they
use barn owl
his real cool stuff though he was on
young justice he's a cool splash later
bart allen in the new 52 sucks
everybody hated the first bar and alan
story didn't do they won a young justice
partner they were like bring back the
old barnell and people
but um we knew 52 had an entire share of
problems they had all kinds of problems
yeah like whatever sal had this amazing
analogy there's amazing like discussion
on on the weekly poll
and he was like you know how the new 52
happened and it was like i don't know
it's like okay so we're gonna have this
story called flashpoint and the flash is
gonna go back in time he's gonna save
his mom's life he's gonna screw up the
universe but then he's gonna go back and
he's gonna let her die then he's gonna
go back to the present everything's
gonna be okay and he's like and then dan
denial was like but what if he did
like what if we did a crisis right now
we're just gonna reboot right now and it
was like what are you even talking about
it's like yes we're going to reboot
everything we're not going to plan it
out we're just going to do it and that's
what happened
no he's just he was making a joke for
this i mean that's probably where i just
like the idea of the meeting room um and
so flashpoint ended i feel really good
about this story and really cohesive
ending and then someone just slams their
death slams their hands on the desk
crisis crisis what crisis what if you're
one endowed crisis yes that's what dc
did they launched future state it was a
catastrophic failure so they're like you
know what you know what dark crisis
and this crisis that
why not i think that's what i think
that's what the mcu is going to do
i think the marvel cinematic universe is
going to do a crisis on infinite nurse i
think the king dynasty
story
is going to be the first half of that
it's going to be it's going to be move
counter so it's going to be king making
this move the king dynasty i don't think
is about the idea of a bunch of kings a
council of kings
i think the king dynasty is what they're
calling king's avengers
he's going to have his own team
right because if he can manipulate time
and control control time
he can jump in and out of moments in
between time which means he could have
smashed wanda out from
dr strange too
and just been like ally yourself with me
and i will i will actually show you a
universe where you have kids that would
love to have you as their mom
because your mom's dead could you go
back in time and like pick somebody out
like cap
things yeah that doesn't think he can
jump he can jump back and forth through
time he can go anywhere and
now it may be one of those things who
they already built up the idea of nexus
event so maybe captain america is just
an incredible one no matter what happens
we'll never get like hydrocat this cat's
just incredible in every universe across
the multiverse steve rogers is the
scrawny ass kid who becomes captain
america with an incorruptible morality
and it's just like no tony stark freedom
because reasons you know and like that
said i still think they're going to be
multiple gangs though i think that would
that would lead into the fact that there
was already another tank in loki and
like i don't think no that's the king
they showed in quantity oh was it what
okay okay the king they showed in loki
that's the king from quantomania
he didn't matter
it was no no no no no no that's immortal
that morris is dead
he who remains his dead when he was
killed
it basically opened the doorway because
the the eye okay so the idea as far as i
understand from the writers and all that
kind of stuff yeah is is you had you had
the multiverse right multiple universes
operating
together uh-huh the multiverse
way back at some point in time
and then one of the one of the kings
realized that he could cross over
two different universes and the other
kings all realize it at the same time
and so all these kings started going to
war against each other in
multi-groups
so what he who remains did is he
separated
every reality that led to his creation
from the entire greater multiverse okay
okay and so that's why you got this
sacred timeline that's why you still had
a multiverse it just wasn't connected to
the rest of them
what loki and silvi did is they started
like when they when they did what they
did when sylvia killed immortus
it slammed it back
what it did is it created a whole bunch
of threads that basically reconnected so
maybe it's still i don't know where it
is in this position but the point is
that it's reconnected with the rest of
the multiverse which is still hanging
out here somewhere and now he controls
all of this as well presumably
that's the case because they're a little
even now it's still a little bit
confusing but the point is is that when
it was all reconnected
he who remains was gone
that seemingly
kane won the king war
of the multiverse in the beginning which
meant the tsa and all that was formed by
king that's why when loki was thrown
back to the tsa
um because he was at the end of time so
when he was thought it was a statue of
king instead of the time keepers and so
he just came to one so hang in at the
end below these series of statues that's
the thing we see in front of me
he's the main bell
and he's going to be and still see her
wars it's going to be
king's avengers team which is different
avengers from different places across
the timeline they were controlled
manipulated or whatever
fingers crossed and some of them are
avengers that we haven't seen yet that
we've always wanted to see so like king
hyperion or something like that
um and then the other is going to be
like dr strange's team and like all the
good guys from across the multiverse
different points in time probably some
other variation of the illuminati or
something like that who are going to be
fighting against the forces
so it's going to be secret wars insofar
as you and i don't know about it because
it's secret out there in the multiverse
and like that's it but once it's done
right you're looking at
the multiversal
plots
and all you have is what they did with
questionable reverse before you had
new earth
one single ton
and that's it and i think that's going
to be the way they're going to
consolidate
everything with that
because it did say that it's ending the
multiverse ending the multiverse science
and so i think that's how they're going
to end the multiverse all right the
marsupial universe is going to crisis on
infinite earths with king dynasty and
superiors i think that would help a lot
with the truth that's our video on king
by the way
so there you go